that is one of the most romantic movie
moments ever different wing or getting
swept off her feet carried away by
Richard Gere I am such a sucker for
seems like that I know me too you know
Debra Winger was the number one female
star back in the early 80s so good to
see her back again this time though on
television I love seeing you in the
sitcom world what was it that drew you
to this show I think the fact that I
hadn't done it before put them on your
feet
Tom Brady wears looks like Marcia Brady
wears them okay but what hasn't Debra
done I mean three Oscar nods and so many
iconic roles urban cowboy hey [ __ ]
there I just watch okay an officer and a
gentleman
terms of endearment Deborah with the
obvious success do you think it heralds
a comeback of the old fashioned movie I
don't know I feel like all the films
I've done have been old-fashioned movies
you might have missed this one playing
Wonder Woman's little sister on TV
let's throw back now 34 years to Debra's
first et interview in 1982 talking about
filming a nude scene it was hard for me
to do it just cuz I was embarrassed
could you please no we really don't need
likes thank you
uh no the camera it's okay just turn it
on and leave more recently this was
Debra at her best opposite Anne Hathaway
in 2008 Rachel Getting Married you were
good with him when wieners newest role
is actually treated it's like here mom I
got a tribe tomorrow me get a whiskey as
mother to Ashton Kutcher and Danny
Masterson on the ranch streaming now on
netflix she's pretty badass do you think
you could hang with her I definitely
could hang with her have hung with her
and you
continue to hang with it well you are
gorgeous and absolutely ageless and you
made some comments recently about how
everyone should just look their age in
Hollywood have you felt that kind of
pressure
uh no I mean I you know you say ageless
and so then you think with age is the
opposite of that but I think I'm pretty
pretty clear about feeling good and
trying to maintain my authentic self so
at age sixty what's her secret I think
it's really good to laugh amen